- All right.
All right, all right, all right.
Hey, thanks everyone who sat down.
We'll get into it in just a second.
I appreciate, maybe you're
here to take a break.
Maybe you just really want
to know about agentic AI
and cloud security.
Either way is fine with me.
So let me dive right in.
And along the way, I may
raise your hand or something,
but let's see how that goes.
So let's get started.
I'm gonna talk a little bit
about what makes AI agentic.
You probably all know very well
about that at this point in time,
especially having been here
for a few days at at re:Invent.
We'll talk about how it can
play a role as a new teammate
and why that's gonna be valuable.
And then how can this shift
how we do things in cloud security.
And I'm gonna show you
one of the workflows
that Sysdig has
implemented using AI agents
to help relieve some of the toil,
some of the pain that exists
when we're talking about
securing our clouds,
our workloads and so on.
I'm actually gonna show
you a little bit of that,
and then at the end, invite
you to come talk to us
in our booth.
So with that, let's get started.
So what makes AI agentic?
Again, I think most of you are
clear on this at this point,
but let's go over it, right?
We wanna move from just
being able to ask a question
and getting some sort of information back
to actually giving AI a
job to do for us, right?
So that it can then act with
autonomy around the clock.
I don't need to be there saying,
how should I do this?
What should I do next and so on?
It's gonna do things
for you independently.
It's gonna learn, it's gonna adapt,
it's gonna use things
that are at its disposal
to do whatever job you give it.
And we're gonna talk about the job
that it can do for you in
the world of cloud security.
And it thinks it collaborates.
I like the collaborate word
because if you were here
for the last presentation,
there's a lot of fear about
this is gonna take my job.
Well, what we really want to do,
and I've experienced this in my own role,
is use AI to help make
what I do more effective,
and maybe I can even get
some time back in my day,
so to speak.
So we wanna use AI to do things
that are relatively complex
that we can allow it to do,
that I don't have to do any longer.
And it becomes not just a
tool, but like a teammate.
And by that I mean, just think about,
regardless of the use case,
think about having something
that can do analysis
that normally I'm doing, but
it can present findings to me,
concise, clear,
so I get exactly what's needed.
Or maybe it's a recommendation.
This is the thing you should do next,
and here's how to do it.
That's awesome.
And then in the future,
and I don't think we're there yet,
you may agree or disagree with me,
but I've actually said, this is your job,
when necessary, do it.
In the world of cloud security,
we're still a little nervous about having,
or in any world, having AI making changes,
tweaking something for fear that
something catastrophic will happen.
I really believe we're gonna get there
to where we'll allow
AI to do things for us.
Maybe it's that I can quickly
look and say, yep, go do it,
but we will get there.
So what we want is
something that helps us,
that grows with us, that
helps every step of the way.
Now, when we think about this
in the world of security,
I want to know anyone here, a
security person, professional,
got a couple, anyone in dev
that has to fix things
like vulnerabilities?
Exactly.
Posture, so on and so forth.
So you know what I'm talking about.
There's all this world of data.
The bigger we get in our clouds,
the bigger we get with our workloads,
the more signals come our way.
And it can become a bit painful
because I need to analyze that stuff.
Hopefully the tool's doing it for me,
but often I get it just
a dashboard, right?
And then what am I gonna
do to filter through that?
What am I gonna do to prioritize
the list of things that
could impact my business?
What am I gonna do to
notify the right people?
How can I get the right recommendations
without having to go swivel in my chair
and ask you what's the best
way to fix this thing, right?
And eventually, again,
getting to a world of action
so that I, on the right hand side,
have a much more concise set
of insights and information
that I can deal with and be
more effective at what I do
when trying to secure
workloads, infrastructure,
all the things in my cloud.
We are seeing it like this.
And what typically is the case today
is that an alert will happen, right?
And when that alert happens,
I'm gonna do some things.
What is the problem?
Let me go investigate.
Is this real?
Is this not real?
Who's involved?
Maybe you are,
oh, I need to go talk to John
because this is something that he did.
What is the impact,
whether something that
actually has happened
or something that could be
the impact of the issue?
Then I get around to figuring out
what am I gonna do to fix it.
In the world of AI,
using agents to help us get
more insights immediately
when something happens,
I still get alerted,
Hey, this thing happened or is happening.
Maybe it's a runtime event,
maybe there's just
vulnerabilities or whatnot.
But what I get immediately
is this is the impact or potential impact.
This is the set of suggestions
and recommendations
that we make for you so that
you can make a quick decision.
And then again, in the world
of getting trust eventually,
saying, go auto fix that for me.
So I am bypassing all of these steps
that take minutes, hours, sometimes days,
and I'm getting all that upfront.
And then if I need to go verify,
I have all the evidence that I can say,
okay, why do you think this is important?
What are the signals that led to this
that came from this problem?
So we want to kind of shift the workflow
from this long process
before I start fixing
to understanding fixing
And then if I need to, I get
more insights and information.
So one of the use cases that
we're using this at Sysdig
is around vulnerability management.
Now, one of the big complaints we hear,
especially in the world of containers,
anyone doing containers in here?
Kubernetes?
Yeah, most of you.
I'm using these things, I scan them,
but so many findings that
I can't stay ahead of it.
And I'm not sure exactly how to prioritize
or I do know how, but I'm
bouncing between a CMDB
or a spreadsheet,
and I'm doing this and I'm doing that.
I've gotta gather my own context.
Well, what if we could leverage
AI to make that better?
This is where I'm just
gonna tell you a little bit.
I'm from Sysdig.
Anyone heard of Sysdig before?
This is the risky question, right?
Yeah, okay.
We are a cloud security platform.
And as a cloud security platform,
we bring a number of
different disciplines,
different, let's call them use cases
from vulnerability management, posture,
all the way through what
we're well known for
is real time threat detection.
And so this is where we have
a lot of good insights, good data,
really deep telemetry, excellent context.
And all of this stuff can be
grabbed and leverage by AI
when trying to solve a problem.
So let me paint the picture of the problem
that we're solving.
One, I saw a lot of head nodding,
a lot of vulnerabilities, right?
Thousands and thousands, right?
And then what do I need to do?
I need to answer a bunch of questions.
Is it really something
I need to worry about?
Is it running in production
or is this just something
we're playing with
in the back, right?
Is it a business critical app?
Is this particular vulnerable
thing even being used?
Is it in memory?
Is it loaded?
Is it exposed?
Is there a fix?
Who owns the fix?
These are all things that
someone in your business
is figuring out and
spending hours and hours
and hours and hours on this weekly,
daily, weekly, monthly, yearly.
Then I need to prioritize that list,
open tickets for the right people.
Then I need to determine how to fix it.
Not I, but the person I just
shipped it off to, right?
They get a Jira ticket and they're like,
okay, now what?
A bunch of CVEs.
Which it's like, okay,
that's a bit of a challenge.
And then of course, I want to
be able to report on progress.
And so this is something
that AI can be very good
at helping us to solve
by pulling together a lot
of these pieces for us.
Here's how we're doing it at Sysdig.
One is looking into your environment.
And in this case, I'm thinking about
like a Kubernetes, EKS, ECS,
maybe some Fargate and so on, right?
I'm looking and identifying,
is this a production cluster?
Does it look like a business application?
Is there data that's at a task,
or is it just some file server
that no one really cares about so on?
Getting that insights.
Then understanding from
a runtime perspective.
Is the vulnerable thing actually in use?
Because that's important, I
want to fix those things first.
And then is it exposed externally?
That's not that hard to do,
but think about pulling that insight in.
And then is there a known exploit?
Can I actually even fix it
or do I need to put a
mitigating control in?
And how am I gonna fix this?
So on this first one is kind
of assisting innovation,
where we're actually looking
into your cloud environment
and looking for business signals.
Why?
To put them in buckets.
Buckets to say this, this.
Let's say I'm in the gaming industry,
like this application
is running everything
that all my users are betting,
doing all the things we're in Vegas.
That makes sense, right?
So identifying that for me
versus something that's less important,
reasoning about it,
and then giving that
information back to me.
Then we can get from
this really big number
to this really small number.
Where then yes, we want
a human to be involved.
We want a human to take action for us.
So let me show you the implementation
that we have at Sysdig.
Then we'll wrap up, we'll
be pretty much done.
We're halfway through.
Alright, I'm gonna switch to my demo.
So I'm just on my home screen here.
Sysdig does a lot of things around vulns,
around runtime events.
So runtime is a very important aspect
of your cloud security.
Things around compliance
and so forth, right?
So what I'm gonna go to
is where we have implemented today
our agentic insights around
vulnerability management.
Now you see my funnel, right?
This is something that
happens to most of us.
We get up with thousands,
thousands of vulnerabilities.
How can something help
me narrow that down?
And in this case, I'm
talking about AI agents
for each one of these steps
going and getting the information,
pulling it together for me.
And then even in the end,
providing a strategy
on how I'm going to fix
said vulnerability or vulnerabilities.
Let me go through each
one of these things.
So one, we've already scanned,
we figured out that there's
some critical vulnerabilities.
Most of us want to fix those
first and foremost, right?
Then is it loaded in memory?
That's some other signal
that Sysdig has as a platform
that AI will,
okay, yeah, we've got
that, we've collected that.
Then what environment is it in, right?
So if automatically identified
some of my environments for me,
I haven't had to go out
and tag these things.
So let's say I'm just
worried about production.
Now that number went
down from not enough from
1200 to just over a thousand.
So I still got a lot in production.
And that's concerning,
but which ones are actually
exposed to the internet
that somebody can get
to and start to exploit?
I'm now down to a much smaller number.
And then are they exploitable?
So from our CVE databases,
is there a known way
that the bad guys are actually getting in
and messing around with this
to try and get into my AWS
cloud or my Kubernetes clusters?
And then there may be
some that are exceptions.
Now today, someone has to go in and say,
yeah, this is their
boss, but it's critical.
But it's a Windows thing
and we use no Windows packages
in anything that we do.
So what if AI could identify
that characteristic for me
and say that's exception.
If I need to dig under the cover
and get an explanation
of why it's an exception,
I can easily get that as well, right?
So that's step one, what
we call removing the noise.
Step two is I'm plotting these
things against the graph,
a graph that says,
one, how important do we deem this to be
and how pervasive I should go this way,
how pervasive is it in my environment?
Meaning is it deployed a ton
across all the things I have?
And you'll see one outlier here,
it's not so high up here,
but it certainly is
deployed in a lot of places.
Now I may think,
okay, you're telling me that
this is probably one to fix?
Explain that to me.
So already, there are
some things I can do.
One is I can just ask.
Explain to me why you
think this is important.
And now this is part of
the generative piece,
which is going to give me
some insights and information
as to why this is deemed one
of the more important images.
This is a container image
I'm talking about here.
And I get some information,
I get various things.
I can actually do things like,
well, then highlight just
critical ones for me.
But I also get is something
that says, fix here.
Now, remember what I said earlier?
We're not quite ready to have AI
just go out and start
making updates for me,
but I can,
I'll call it a recipe.
I can get a recipe for what to do.
And now, instead of me sending
over to you a Jira ticket
that says, here's your list
of CVEs, please fix them,
I can say here's the list of CVEs,
here's where they're running.
By the way, these are in use
and let me go ahead and click this button.
And here's what we recommend that you do.
Now, this is a set of recommendations,
both from a app level,
in this case, again, container image
as well as a base layer to say, do this.
Now, it's smart enough to
understand your environment.
Number one, again,
AI agents have understood
your environment.
Two, it's smart enough not to say,
okay, yeah, bump up from
version three to four of Redis
or whatever, right?
We don't want to do that
because that might introduce
some things that break.
So that's the benefit of having this,
is that now I get everything that I need
enumerated, listed,
even some commands that can be
ran by the dev who gets this.
And I can easily say,
okay, let's create a Jira ticket
and I'm off and flying, right?
So what's cool about this
is that that payload or that recipe,
let's call this,
I'm gonna put it in my area here
and we'll call it a task,
is that that payload of
insights and information
gets dropped into ticket.
And now that is nicely formatted
for the person who receives it
and they can go about fixing it.
So now instead of having this
really, really long process
of filtering, prioritizing,
figuring out how to fix it,
AI has sort of brought
that to my doorstep.
And that's what I love about this,
is that we're gonna end up
helping save a lot of time,
a lot of sneaker wear.
Again, a lot of trying to ask a friend
or go on search the
internet for things, right?
So I can create that ticket.
If I already have one open,
it knows I already have one open.
And that's beautiful.
So that's one of the ways that
we've implemented agentic AI.
And then again, for most of us,
let me go,
I'm gonna do this the brute force way.
We also want to track how are we doing?
Typically, you want this to
go down into the right, right?
So AI can help us keep track of that too.
I can show this to my boss,
I can show this to whomever
and have a nice track record.
Or if it's going the wrong way,
I'm going to put a little more
time and effort into this.
And so that's a little bit about
how something like a
well-guided set of AI agents,
agentic AI, if you will,
let me go back here,
can help you
get out from under some
of this really hard work.
Now we see this being applicable
across all of the domains
of cloud security,
posture management, threat detection,
finding ways to have AI help us
do some of the jobs that
today I just I'm having to do
and it's not really that important of work
other than I'm spending time
filtering through various
pieces of information.
Let's let AI do that.
I can get down to the fixing.
So I'm gonna close it here.
Nothing too heavy.
Hopefully that's okay
with you guys, right?
It's helping to transform things.
We're getting help with
defending our clouds.
We're help getting help
making faster decisions
for response,
which is key to staying ahead
of threats in the cloud.
And now I'm empowering every one of you
to have the information in a
little bit of an easier way
than is currently the state-of-the-art
for most security tools out there.
You can come see this, learn
more over in our booth,
ask us some questions over there.
So with that, I'm gonna wrap up
and just say thank you for being here.
Hopefully you get some insights into that
and start looking for these kind of things
in your shop when you
need to actually deliver
security tooling and security
approaches for your business.
That's all I got.
Thank you everyone for being here.
Appreciate it.
(audience clapping)